[Music]
properly executed a good twist can
elevate a film to the next level
but some movies just don't know when to
stop piling it on
from sci-fi flicks to mystery movies
these are the plot twists that went too
far
but be warned major spoilers are ahead
since daniel craig took over as james
bond of 2006's casino royale double
those seven films have tended towards
becoming darker
more personal and less pulpy in each
installment
at least this was the case until 2015
spectre the film features a longer way
to
return a recurring villain and stavro
blofeld leader of the criminal
organization
spectre near the end of the movie bun
discovers that blofeld is not only
behind
all of the evil plots that he's faced
over the past three films
he's also responsible for every major
personal misfortune that bond has ever
suffered
this is because get ready for it blofeld
is actually james bond's long-lost and
vindictive adoptive
brother we understand why this twist
makes sense on paper
conventional wisdom states that the more
powerful the villain the more interest
in the conflict
and also that villain should have a
personal relationship with the hero the
logical end point of this is to give
james bond an evil brother who
single-handedly controls all the crime
in the world
unfortunately this also means that the
once large and indifferent world that
bond fought against
has now been reduced to a family
squabble there's nothing wrong with that
but it's not what made the craig era
bond film so great
in the 2009 film splice cutting edge
geneticists clive and elsa
are forbidden by their bosses from using
human dna in their experiments
so they decide to ignore the orders and
continue their experiments in secret
in doing this they create dren a
near-human multi-species hybrid clive
and elsa take it upon themselves to
covertly raise jiren as her own daughter
and she starts maturing extremely fast
going through childhood adolescence and
adulthood over the course of the film
the twist in splice isn't one moment
where everything
suddenly goes wrong it's more like a
series of disturbing developments that
culminate in a genuinely upsetting
fiasco of a climax for starters when
dren is a newborn five attempts to drown
her but it turns out that she has
amphibious lungs
elsa eventually reveals that she herself
donated her own dna to make
up dren's human half not some anonymous
donor once dren reaches adulthood she
and clive begin to have a physical
relationship
then towards the end of the film dren
spontaneously changes gender becoming
male
hyper violent and territorial finally
dren kills clive and assaults elsa
who is forced to bludgeon dren to death
with a rock and as if that wasn't enough
the film ends with a reveal that elsa is
pregnant with dren's baby
at times the script of splice seems to
exist merely to violate every possible
taboo that the writer could think of
with no deep meaning or philosophy at
its core
it certainly makes for a compelling film
but only because you're waiting to see
what else could possibly happen
released in 2009 orphan tells the story
of kate and john coleman
a couple who adopt a child named esther
from a local orphanage
at first their new daughter seems sweet
and innocent but as time goes on
the commons begin to suspect that esther
might have a dark side
in his first two acts orphan is a fairly
competent execution of the classic evil
child horror story
and then it completely goes off the
rails in act 3. throughout the film
esther seems to have a surprising amount
of knowledge of and interest in adult
relationships
despite being obsessively 9 years old
this culminates with her unsuccessfully
attempting to seduce her father which
causes him and kate to start digging
into esther's past
kate learns the truth that esther isn't
really a child she's a 33 year old woman
with a condition called republicarism
which stunted her growth she uses her
childlike appearance to take advantage
of people and she's also a homicidal
maniac
many people found the plot of this film
deeply offensive for multiple reasons
some took issue with the way that it
depicted hypebuppertutorism a real-life
condition that this movie grossly
misrepresents
adoption groups also denounced the film
for similarly obvious reasons
the backlash was so strong that the home
video release of the film
even felt the need to include a
pro-adoption message as a way to
counteract the toxic narrative of the
movie
released in 2019 serenity tells the
story of baker dill
a boat captain who lives on a remote
plymouth island he spends his days
trying to hunt down and catch an elusive
giant fish named justice out of the blue
dill's ex-wife karen shows up and
presents
him with an offer she tells dyl that her
current husband frank is abusing their
son
the quiet and introverted patrick frank
is planning on visiting plymouth island
soon
so karen offers dill 10 million dollars
in cash if he takes frank out on a
fishing trip
and ensures that he never returns so far
so good
but here comes a twist plymouth island
is a game that's right plymouth island
and all of its inhabitants don't really
exist
this world is actually a realistic video
game that was created by anders being
played by
our true protagonist patrick his real
father died a decade earlier
baker dill is a fictionalized version of
patrick's dad that he's using to enact a
cathartic fantasy of killing his
stepfather
and then when dale finally does decide
to knock off frank within the game
patrick similarly works up the courage
to kill frank in the real world
while serenity starts to fall apart
after the twist it's always fun to watch
matthew mcconaughey play an offbeat
character
even one who has a hard time expressing
his emotions
[Music]
the force awakens was a promising start
to a new trilogy ending with an array of
tantalizing unanswered questions perhaps
the most intriguing of all concern the
enigmatic ray
despite being a poor orphan from a
remote planet with no jedi training she
has inexplicably strong force powers
could rey perhaps be the long-lost child
of some great jedi
the next star wars film the last jedi
pulled the rug out from under audiences
by
answering the question of who rey's
parents were in the most shocking way of
all
by saying they were nobodies who sold
their daughter into slavery
then the rise of skywalker was released
in this film ray learns that she is
in fact the long lost granddaughter of
emperor palpatine a reveal that most
found
equal parts confusing and unnecessary
some fans think that this new twist was
added just to appease those who disliked
the reveal in the last jedi but it was
so poorly executed and nonsensical that
it seemed more like a cleanup job than a
genuine plot point
what a practical situation fantastic
bees somewhere to find them
opened with a montage of news headlines
telling us that the evil wizard gathered
grindelwald
is still at large and could be anywhere
a segment is brief but important info
for the upcoming
twist then the film proper begins our
hero newt scamander is a major zoologist
who's just arrived in new york in 1926
with a suitcase full of rare magical
creatures
scamander soon runs afoul of percival
graves a high-ranking official in the
magical government of the united states
graves asserts that one of scamander's
creatures is responsible for the death
of a local politician
but in truth the graves is attempting to
frame scamander to cover up his own
crimes
once graves is exposed and defeated
scamander discovers that graves has
magically disguised his appearance
after dispelling his magic scamander
reveals that percival graves is actually
in a shockingly underwhelming twist
gellert grindelwald what did he add to
that to be fair grindelwald is an
important figure in larger harry potter
lore but up until now within this
particular story he did not matter at
all
sure we technically got a bit of a tease
about grindelwald at the very beginning
but he was barely mentioned throughout
the rest of the film
when he finally appeared many viewers
had totally forgotten about him while
some die-hard harry potter fans thought
this was a cool reveal
others thought it was a bit confusing or
even worse laughable
when a dangerous patient named rachel
salando mysteriously vanishes from a
maximum security mental hospital
us marshal edward teddy daniels arrives
on shutter island to solve the case as
he digs deeper teddy begins to suspect
that andrew latest the man who is
responsible for his wife's death
is also somewhere on the island and he
vows to find him as well
after a series of surreal visions and
frightening encounters
teddy makes a horrifying discovery in
truth he is andrew ladis a patient at
this facility
he killed his own wife and this entire
investigation was an elaborate role-play
therapy
staged by his doctors to give him a
chance to confront his demons
the big kicker edward daniels is an
anagram for andrew leydis
and rachel salander was an anagram for
his wife's name dolores channel
when shutter island hit theaters it
received a lukewarm response from
critics and audiences
the blood device of a man investigating
a homicide only to discover that he is
the killer has been done much better in
other movies
shutter island is still a decent film so
it's hard to get too worked up over this
one
but did we really need another movie
where it was all in his head
excuse me in the 2018 film upgrade
great trace and his wife are attacked by
mysterious assailants grey ends up
paralyzed and his wife is killed
shortly after tech mogul aaron keane
offers grey a chance to walk again by
installing a prototype ai chip named
stem
into his spine he accepts and after the
procedure gray finds out that not only
can he walk again he can also
temporarily gain superhuman reflexes by
giving control of his body to stem
grey then uses these abilities to get
revenge on the people who attacked him
through a series of thrilling and brutal
action sequences
in the end gray discovers that his
friend keen hired the goons that
attacked him but it wasn't keane's idea
it was stems after keane invented stem
the ai forced him to participate in a
plan to give itself a human body which
ended up being grace
so how does our hero win the day well
unfortunately he doesn't there's a
moment where we think he's one grey
appears in a hospital bed alongside his
still-living wife
but this is in fact just a fantasy world
that grey is trapped in
stem has now taken full control of
grey's body permanently
between the rich benefactor is evil the
ai is evil and the happy ending is
actually a dream
upgrade as three fairly tired sci-fi
cliches woven into its plot
taken together they end this almost
great movie on a gratuitously bleak note
i'm not proud of it with a little more
restraint now you see me could have
easily been a fun and glamorous crime
romp
a lotions 11 or catch me if you can the
film was a globe trotting cat and mouse
chase between fbi investigator dylan
rhodes and a group of robin hood s
criminal magicians called the four
horsemen
that premise alone could be more than
enough for a cool heist film but this
movie just doesn't know when to quit
layered on top of that rose discovers
that the horsemen have ties to an
ancient order of wizards called the eye
with real magical powers but that's not
all the final twist is that although
rose has been attempting to catch the
horseman he's secretly their leader and
a member of the eye
presumably rose's entire multi-decade
fbi career was a long con so that he
could serve as a group's inside man for
a single heist this idea is so
inconceivably elaborate that it
completely shatters the reality of the
film
even more than the actual magic does
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you